governor cuomo taking some heat for
forcing children in a long island school
district to wear masks until further
notice
the move going against both state and
federal health guidance
my next guest writing about this in an
op-ed saying cuomo is using his waning
power to block
mask sanity for kids joining me now
carol markowitz
new york post columnist carol great to
see you this morning thanks for being
here
um explain your headline there he has
gone against the
comac school district in long island and
i'm going to show actually a little
let's show a little piece of what they
said
they said when we explained to the
governor's office our strictness in
keeping students six feet apart since
the beginning of the school year
they indicated that didn't matter we
were directed that masks
must be worn at all times so what's the
governor up to here
so throughout the pandemic the governor
has sort of been flip-flopping back and
forth as to whether or not he's in
charge of schools in
april of last year when he got into one
of his many brawls with mayor bill de
blasio he said he was in charge of
schools then when it was time to open
schools he wasn't in charge of schools
and so on he did this back and forth
several times
so now we're reaching another point
where his own department of health said
that if kids are six feet apart
they can take off their masks he has
overruled his own department of health
to step in
and say he's actually in charge and the
school district cannot do
what science says that they should yeah
i mean it really is remarkable
because when you look at the science on
this uh these kids in many cases
there were kids all across the country
who went back to school in september
all over the place yeah so and even in
his own city carol
i mean all the catholic school kids were
in a city right down the street so how
does he justify
becoming more strict when you know when
the neighbor down the street has been in
school
since september yeah
and there's also kids in many school
districts across the country who
are go to mass optional schools and
we've gotten to the point where our rate
is so low
kids should have never been wearing
masks in the first place but now it's
there's just no argument to be made
anymore an unvaccinated child has about
the same chance as a vaccinated adult of
contracting covet and probably even less
likelihood than that of passing it on
so we've reached a point where nobody
should be wearing masks in schools but
if they want to continue doing that
through the end of the year if you're in
a school that wants to do that that's
fine
but they should be able to decide for
themselves it should be a decision
between
the school district parents doctors not
governor cuomo
it's a great point i mean at the point
that we're at
given the science that we have allow the
family to make their own decision
i mean i read a thread on twitter last
night that just shocked me it was you
know all these people saying
they don't want to take their masks off
they're not comfortable taking their
masks off they feel like if their child
doesn't have a mask
on they're you know they're a threat to
everyone around them and
there's absolutely no science that backs
that up you know politically it's
interesting when you look back at the de
blasio story which you just mentioned
in the very beginning of this mayor de
blasio's instinct
told him that the students should stay
in school he said you know their parents
have to go to work
they should stay in school they're going
to be safe in school and this was before
we knew a lot about transmission
but he got shut down in a big way on
that by governor cuomo i think that was
an interesting moment in this story
yeah i agree and actually it's funny i
mentioned in my column but
bill de blasio wanted to open schools at
so many different points but he just
wasn't strong enough to stand up to the
teachers unions and
governor cuomo has sort of you know been
hands off and let him take the lead on
this
because he too does not want to get into
a scuffle with the teachers union so
we have these two really weak
politicians who won't stand up for kids
and won't stand up to teachers unions
and they continue to behave in a really
passive way and not doing the right
thing for kids and i think that's why
people are so scared today
because they see their leadership not
standing up for them not saying it's
okay for kids to unmask finally
and i think if governor cuomo did that
it would go a long way towards the
mental health of these people who are so
afraid yeah
it's a great point the unions may have
lost some of their power as we see
students leaving the public school
system in droves
but they still are big contributors to
democratic campaigns so
that may be what's talking here carol
great piece as always good to see you
thanks for being here today
thank you so much you thank you